i'm reporting from taiwan
where this island is increasingly
becoming a focal point between u.s
and china tensions i'm going to take you
to three places
to explain how the competitions between
the two super powers
from the tech to the military could
determine the future of this place
but first a little history about why
taiwan is so important to china
this island was where the chinese
nationalist party fled after its
military defeat
at the end of the chinese civil war in
[Music]
1949
today taiwan hosts democratic elections
uses a defense passport and has its own
distinct flag
and while some politicians here support
closer ties with beijing
many people have gone uncomfortable with
that idea
this is our first stop the capital of
taiwan
taipei here are growing numbers of young
taiwanese
supports closer ties with the u.s
overclose relations with china
[Music]
security experts say this kind of
statement commitmentary actions that
push the u.s
into conflict unrecently there's been a
lot
more material activity in the street
between the island and mainland china
this is the strait of taiwan the wall
street journal ideally of how many
chinese warplanes were in norwegian
using information from taiwan's defense
ministry and we find that
in 2020 china sends about 380 warplanes
to this region
but this year there were already above
219 warplanes
u.s officials and former taiwanese
military leaders say
taiwan will need to do more to be able
to fend off an invasion from china
especially since chinese has a hundred
times as many ground force personnel
as taiwan china's annual material budget
is also 25 times larger
so in an attempt to fill the gap last
year taiwan increased military spending
by 10
and has been purchasing weapons from the
u.s
but some military analysts say is not in
china's interest to attack
the seas around and taiwan's coastline
made it difficult for warship to land
most importantly an invasion could
prompt a monetary response from the u.s
which would likely escalate but if not a
military conflict
taiwan provides at least one more area
of competition between the u.s and china
behind me is the headquarters of tsmc
the world's largest contract trip maker
its trips ends up in our smartphone
and laptop but now because of a global
chip shortage
taiwan is becoming more important to the
us and china
that's because tfmc controls more than
90 of the market for the most advanced
[Music]
semiconductors
tsmc has tried to walk the night between
china and the u.s
but the tension between these two
countries has makes this difficult
especially after washington restrict
chinese telecom giant's huawei's
access to tsmc over national security
concerns
the term administration instructed an
american supplier to stop working with
tsmc
it is kept exporting ships to huawei
[Music]
to reduce its dependence on taiwan
chinese has made ship manufacturing a
priority
so has the u.s with a commitment of 50
billion dollars to building up that
sector
we're investing aggressively in areas
like semiconductors and batteries that's
what they're
doing and others so must we
but it would take years before these
efforts barefoot giving the u.s
and china yet another reason to focus on
taiwan
and i can say with confidence that the
united states partnership with taiyan
taiwan is stronger than ever
ultimately the future of this island is
going to be a key challenge for the bad
administration
so the u.s will have to find the white
balance between supporting taiwan
while making sure ongoing tensions with
china doesn't ask you like further